عندما صفر حكم مباراه اليابان واسبانيا
قبل ايام معلنا الهدفا ثانيا للمنتخب
الياباني اقصى المانيا من كاس العالم
ومنحت تاهل لمحاربي الساموراي اعتراض
الكثيرون بحجه ان الكره خرجت من الملعب
الا ان التكنولوجيا كان لها راي اخر حيث
اقرت تقنيه البر ان الكره لم تتجاوز خط
الملعب بشكل كامل وبقي ظلالها فيه اكتسب
الهدف وتتاهل اليابان على حسابي المانيا
اليوم اصبحت التكنولوجيا جزء هامه في كره
القدم خصوصا في المباريات الجاريه في
الملاعب كاس العالم في قطر مساعد
ضيعه عده مستخدمه في مونديال 2002 و20 لعل
ابرزها تقنيه حكم الفيديو المساعد بار
التي تعين حكام اللعبه على اكتشاف الاخطاء
التي يصعب عليهم كشفها على الفور بسبب
سرعه اللعب وتعتمد على مجموعه حكام يجلسون
في غرفه داخل الملعب يعيدون اللقطات
ويتواصلون مع حكم الساحه ليمدونه
بالمعلومات عن الحالات التحكيميه ايضا
تقنيه خط المرمى جول لاين هي المسؤوله عن
تحديد ما اذا كانت الكره قد دخلت المرمى
بالفعل ام لا حيث تساعد على احتساب
الاهداف المشقوق فيها فيما اذا كانت الكره
دخلت بكامل محيطها في المرمى كذلك تقنيه
التسلل شبه الالي هي تقنيه مدعومه بنهجه
تتبع الاطراف الجديد من خلال مستشعر في
الكره وكاميرات مخصصه في الملاعب تستخدم
بيانات معينه ترسل 500
مره كل ثانيه لتحديد ما اذا كان اللاعب
متسللا ام لا كذلك فان كره المونديال
الرسميه واسمها الرحله تعد احدى اكثر
الكرات دقه في العالم حيث تحتوي على
رقاقات ذكيه لقياس سرعه الركله وتساعد
ايضا في التسلل شبه الالي وتحلل بيانات
اللاعبين ويمكن شحنها كهربائيه
[موسيقى]
من الدوحه ينضم الى الصحافه الرياضي محمد
يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا لاول مره صباح
العربيه من الممتعه
اهلا اختي اهلا زملا الكرام ومرحبا بكل
مشاهدي قناه العربيه يعني من الكره الذكيه
الرحله الى تقنيه تسلل شبه الالي حديثنا
اكثر عن التقنيات ذكيه الجديده المستخدمه
في مونديال قطر لاول مره
وضعتها الفيفا في استخدام همم كل مباريات
مونديال قطر 2022 مونديال قطر الذي رفع
مستوى اللعبه الى مستوى اخر تماما من حيث
التقنيه والتكنولوجيه همم هناك العديد من
التكنولوجيه التي همم تحسم العديد من
الحالات الجدليه هنا في مباريات الجاريه
في هذا المونديال التقنيه همم الشبه الالي
تكنولوجيا الشبه الاليه التي تعتمد على 12
كاميرا كامله مركبه تحت همم اسقف الملاعب
تتتبع 29 نقطه كامله من اجساد اللاعبين
هذا ما يضع هامشا تقريبا للخطا في حركه
اللاعبين وحركه الكره همم اماكن تواجد
اللاعبين واماكن تم تواجد الكره اماكن
تواجد اللاعبين همم في التوقيت المناسب
والدقيق لخروج الكره من ارجل اللاعب
الممرر نحو اللاعب المستقبل همم تكنولوجيه
اتاحت همم او قضت كثيرا على هامش الخطا
بالنسبه للحكام تساعد الكثير تساعد كثيرا
حكام هذه الدوره على القضاء على الاخطاء
التحكيميه التي تثير الكثير منها الحالات
الجدليه في عالم كره القدم هناك ايضا
تقنيه المستشعر همم الموجود داخل كره
اديداس التي تلعب بها مباريات المونديال
الحاليه هذه التقنيه التي تعتمد على همم
تقنيه القصور الذاتي هكذا همم هذه التقنيه
التي ساعدت في وضع حد لحاله الجدل التي
اثرت في مباراه المنتخب البرتغالي امام
المنتخب الاوروغواياني وانصفت
المنتخب البرتغالي على حساب زميله
كريستيانو رونالدو الذي ادعى همم احقيته
بالهدف المسجل والدعى ان الكره لمست راسه
ولكن في الاخيره التكنولوج
او هذا الجدل وجود كل هذه التقنيات شهدنا
حالات جدليه خلال هذا المونديال لماذا
هناك انتقادات ضد هذه التقنيات وهل بالفعل
يمكن ان تفقد اللعبه الاكثر شعبيه في
العالم
اعتقد ان هذه هي الطبيعه البشريه الاحتجاج
على كل قرار ضد هذا المنتخب او ذاك لا احد
يتقبل قرارات حاسمه ضده مثلا الحاله
الجدليه التي اثارت الكثير منها اللغط في
هذا المونديال في مباراه اليابان امام
المنتخب الاسباني همم بعدما جاء هدف من
كره اعتقد الجميع انها خرجت من الخط ولكن
بالعوده الى التقنيه والى التكنولوجيا
اظهر المستشعر داخل الكره وهمم تقنيه
الشبه الالي ان الكره لم تتجاوز بكامل
قطرها وكامل حجمها همم الخط لذلك الهدف
هدف اليابان كان صحيحا همم تخيل فقط مائي
لو كان همم لو لم تكن هناك هذه التقنيات
حاضره في هذا المونديال كيف سيتصرف الحكام
مع مثل هكذا حالات
هدف المنتخب الياباني التكنولوجيا تساعد
كثيرا على همم وضع العداله اسس لا لا لكل
منتخب لكل لاعب همم تدقق بشكل عظيم وبشكل
كبير جدا في كل كره الى درجه المليمترات
او اقل من المليمترات مثل ما حدث مع همم
الحاله الجدليه في مباراه اليابان
والمنتخب الاسباني همم الان نعود الى همم
الاحتجاجات او همم الاطراف التي تنادي
بعدم او بتقليص الاستعمال التكنولوجي في
كره القدم صحيح ان هذه التكنولوجيا تقلص
بعض الشيء من متعه كره القدم اعطيك مثالا
في العديد من الاحيان تقنيه الفار تتدخل
همم بعد مرور الكثير من الوقت على اللقطات
تعلن همم ركله جزاء لهذا الطرف او ذاك او
تعلن حاله همم
تتدخل بعد فرحه الجماهير يكونوا فرحه
بالهدف شكرا جزيلا
ههه
شكرا لك